Hey everyone, this is Ryan here and welcome back for this next series on endodontics,
one of the main clinical topics that appears on part 2 of the dental board exams.
It's actually tied with pharmacology with having the least amount of questions of all
the sections.
There are only 31 questions out of a total 500.
So with that being said, like all of my videos, I'm going to be focusing only on the highest
yield things you need to know.
While I'm gearing these videos for exam preparation, they are also designed to give you a nice
overview of these topics for clinical application and general knowledge.
So first we're going to go over the biology of the dental pulp, because much of endodontics
is focused on pulp-able health, since endodontics literally translates to the knowledge of what's
within teeth.
So the pulp is obviously very important.
So the pulp is the innermost part of the tooth is generally very soft and vascular.
So let's talk about what specifically is contained within this tissue.
So the pulp contains loose fibrous connective tissue with nerves, blood vessels, and lymphatics.
Again, very vascular.
It contains fibroblasts, which secrete fibrous connective tissue.
It also houses the odontoblast, which secrete dentin.
Now the type of dentin depends on the stage of root formation.
So it's considered primary dentin before root formation is complete and secondary dentin
after root formation is complete.
But odontoblast secrete both types of dentin.
It also contains undifferentiated mesenchymal cells, which can differentiate into a specific
type of cell, which we'll revisit later called secondary odontoblast.
So the confusing thing here is that secondary odontoblast do not secrete secondary dentin.
They actually form tertiary dentin to protect the pulp from injury.
But these undifferentiated mesenchymal cells are basically stem cells that can later on
divide and become new cells.
So the pulp is also surrounded by hard dentin.
So that's what those odontoblast have secreted as the tooth was forming and after it has completed
information.
And so this hard dentin creates a pressure system which limits its ability to expand.
So the pulp, if pressure is building up and some infection has taken place, it has a
lot of trouble expanding against this hard dentin.
Also it lacks collateral circulation, which limits its ability to cope with infection.
So basically there's one one way in, one way out for a two rooted tooth, I guess it has
two ways in and two ways out.
But there are less avenues for immune cells to reach the pulp.
So the pulp tissue as compared to say the skin of your face is already compromised structurally
in terms of being able to fight an infection.
One for the pressure buildup and two for less avenues for immune cells to reach that component.
So the pulp is already anatomically more driven to infection, at least more easily.
So let's talk about that, the dentin and pulp defense.
What can the pulp do rather to fight off or defend itself from an infection?
So sclerotic dentin is basically very hard dentin.
The calcification has occurred of dentinal tubules in response to slowly advancing carries or
just aging, just the physiological process of this dentin getting harder over time.
So sclerotic dentin would be a pulp or response to slowly advancing carries.
Now we have this thing called reactionary dentin, which is a reaction to minor damage.
So reactionary reaction to minor damage.
And some sources would call this another word for secondary dentin.
Now reparative dentin is repair for major damage.
And some textbooks and some sources will refer to this otherwise as the tertiary dentin.
And this makes sense because minor damage wouldn't be enough to destroy the original
Adanta blasts that are pleasant, so it allows them to lay down some dentin.
While major damage would destroy the original Adanta blasts, and so then those undifferentiated
mesenchymal cells need to step up and become secondary Adanta blasts and lay down tertiary
dentin as basically a last resort.
However, many sources just refer to both of these together as tertiary dentin.
But I wouldn't worry too much about these details, it's not too, too important.
More important is to know that reactionary is for minor damage, whereas reparative is
for major damage.
That's much, much more important to know than all the secondary and tertiary stuff.
So in endodontics and operative dentistry, there's this technique referred to as pulp
capping where you place a calcium hydroxide liner, which irritates Adanta blasts, and
they'll form either this reactionary or reparative dentin depending on how close you are to the
pulp.
So this sort of dynamic response of odontoblasts and these secondary Adanta blasts who lay down
new dentin sort of to form this dentinal wall that forms a barrier and defends the pulp.
So the tooth is very alive, as long as it's not necrotic, and it can respond dynamically
to infection, which is pretty cool.
And now of course we have popyl necrosis where the tooth is dead, the pulp has been compromised,
and that's the response to rapidly advancing carries or other severe damage.
And the tooth has lost the battle, and the pulp is now dead.
So in all of these cases, the main cause of serious pulpal injury is always bacteria.
So bacteria can come from a plethora of sources mostly from let's think dental carries or
cavities, and the bacteria are small enough where they can penetrate beyond the obvious
carries and cavities through dentinal tubules to reach the pulp, and that's when problems
can start occurring, the patient can be in pain, and the pulp can become infected and
can die eventually.
Alright, so now let's talk about more specifics of the histology of the dental pulp.
So from outside to inside, we have, well first we have dentin, that's the darkest layer right
here, and then the pre dentin is the innermost portion of dentin, that's the lighter portion
here, and it's lighter because it's not mineralized, and it's located directly adjacent to what
we would consider the actual pulp.
So the odontoblastic layer is where all of these nuclei are, these are the odontoblasts
that are laying down dentin right on the outside, just adjacent to the pulp tissue.
So the odontoblasts again are actually part of the pulp, but they are forming the dentin
just outside of it.
Now right inside the odontoblastic layer is the cell free zone of whale, and that's
this zone right here where there are almost zero nuclei present, and that's because there
are no cells there.
In this region, you'll often see nerve bundles, and we'll talk more about nerves in the next
coming slides.
And then right inside of that is the cell rich zone, and that's where we have a lot
more nuclei, and then inside of that would be the pulp core, the central part of the pulp,
and we will talk more about that as well when we are referring to nerves.
Okay, so we have this thing called dentinal pain, and so this is conducted by these A
delta fibers.
So that's probably the first thing we've talked about so far that's extremely important,
and I would definitely, definitely know that for the exam.
This one, the A delta fiber is large, it's myelinated, and it's an afferent nerve, which
means, or afferent nerve, that means it's carrying nervous information from outside the
body, it's carrying it peripherally towards the center, so it's bringing information into
the body.
And so it's, as you can see in this picture, it's large, it's at least larger than this
one that we're going to talk about in the next slide, it's myelinated, that's what these
darker red portions are, and the nodes of Ranvier between these myelinated sheets, and
it's afferent.
So the dentinal pain that's conducted by these A delta fibers is a sharp transient first
pain, so if you stub your toe, that's the initial really sharp pain that you would feel
from that.
These fibers course coronaly through the pulp, so they're coronaly, as opposed to, say, centrally,
which is where the C fibers are going to be, and dentinal pain is more often than not associated
with cold temperatures.
And now the second type of pain is pulpitus pain, and that's conducted by these C fibers,
so when we compare them to the A delta fibers, they're small, they're unmyelinated, and they're
also afferent nerves, they're carrying this pain information.
As I said before, they course centrally in the pulp stroma.
This one is involved with dull, throbbing second pain, so after you stub your toe, and it hurts
a lot initially, and then it kind of is sore and achy a little bit later, that would be
the second pain, and this is more often associated with heat.
So now that we talked about both of these, you can see this chart here, or this graph,
with time on the x-axis, and the A delta axons are transmitting this first pain, super painful,
and then the second pain sort of creeps up later, and it's a lot longer, maybe not quite
as intense, but it's managed a lot later.
So those are the two different types of pain, and the two different types of fibers associated
with each of those pains.
Now I'll go back one slide real quick, because I wanted to mention that the A delta fibers
are transmitting dentinal pain, because they are associated with the pulpo-dentinal complex,
and so that means where the pulp and the dentin meet, it's a bit more easily provoked, because
dentinal pain is further on the outside, you can say, and because the fibers aren't central
to the pulp, they're more coronal, they're more on the outside, along the outside border,
they're more easily provoked than the C fibers, which are located more central.
And so you can think of it, the progression of pulpl inflammation can change a pain response
from this first pain with A delta axons to become second pain transmitted by the C axons.
All right, next I want to talk about these two really important terms for pain sensitization,
and there are some graphs and drawings you can check out for these terms, but I actually
thought they were very confusing, so I'll try to explain these important terms as best
as I can.
First we have hyperalgezia, which is a heightened response to pain, and then that's compared
to allodynia, which is a reduced pain threshold, so that's pain due to a stimulus that does
not normally provoke pain.
So hyperalgezia would be where you have inflammatory mediators in the pulp that can increase the
intensity of a pain stimulus, in other words, something that's usually painful becomes even
more painful, and for allodynia, I have a great way to remember this, and a great example
of allodynia is sunburn.
So usually touching your skin doesn't hurt, but when it's badly sunburned, it physiologically
hurts when you touch your skin, and alloe is something you often use to treat symptoms
of sunburn, so I think of it like sunburned skin is an example of allodynia, and alloe
being, again, the thing that you would often grab when you're experiencing these terrible
symptoms of a bad sunburn, so hopefully that can help you differentiate and remember between
these two important pain sensitization terms.
And last, I just wanted to review the concept of referred pain, which is important in all
of dentistry, and particularly in the dontics.
So pre-arricular pain often refers from mandibular molars since both share V3 innervation.
Okay, so what does this all mean, and why is it important for anodontics?
So pre-arricular is referring to the region in front of the ear, and you'd think pain
in front of the ears may be referred from, say, maxillary molars because, well, they're
anatomically much closer, but with how the innervation of the face works, as we can see
in this diagram, although they may be anatomically closer, they share, or this area in front of
the ear shares V3 innervation with the mandibular molars.
Since V3 is the mandibular nerve, that is what shares innervation with this part of
the ear.
These molars are often innervated by V2 or the maxillary nerve, and that's not associated
with the pre-arricular region.
The reason I bring this up is because this itself can be a test question.
It's something that you could easily think, well, just because the maxillary molars are
closer to the ear, maybe that could be some referred pain where you feel pain in this
region because those molars are acting up, but really it's more to do with how the innervation
is mapped out onto the face.
So that's it for this video, I hope you found it helpful in our introduction to endodontics
and how pain is transmitted from the teeth, please leave a like if you enjoyed this video
and subscribe to my channel for more on endodontics and all things dentistry.
Thanks so much for watching and I'll see you guys in the next video.